somebody said that that adversity
introduces a man to himself or a woman
how you handle it
that's where the growth takes place one
of the things that we know about life
is that it is always changing sometimes
you're up
sometimes you're down sometimes things
go real well and sometimes they don't
sometimes you're happy and sometimes
you're sad now that's that thing called
life
and when we begin to understand and know
that accepting that reality that that we
will never ever have things just on an
even kill all the time
that you're going to have some ups and
you're going to have some Downs but
during those down moments
that's where the growth takes place
that's where the work is anybody can
feel good when they have their health
their bills are paid they have happy
relationships the children are acting
normal
business is successful
anybody could be positive then anybody
can have a larger Vision then anybody
can have faith under those kinds of
circumstances am I correct see but the
real challenge
the real challenge of growth mentally
emotionally and spiritually comes when
you get knocked down when I was facing
some challenges
I had a guy say something to me and I
suggest this is one of the first things
that you want to do when you're facing a
challenge you want to get unstuck
evaluate where you are look at it assess
yourself assess yourself and assess the
situation what brought you there
what role did you play Earl Nightingale
had a sing I like he said all of us are
self-made but only the successful will
admit it I lived in a car for three
years
all of that that I was going through
that I was tripping with that I did not
appreciate or understand I understand it
now because I'm on the other side of
them troubles the route you on right now
is the route you got to take and it's
very Uniquely Yours
this thing you're going through this
just uniquely yours you just gotta
understand you ain't the only one
you're the only one going through it now
in the order that is going to happen a
lot of pain in my life no more than
nobody else I just had a lot
but I learned along the way
everything that's happening to you is
God is processing you
every difficult moment you're having
he just processing you
that's all he doing
everything you're going through is
preparing you for what you ask God for
and if you need to be tough when you get
to where you're going
then he gonna toughen you
if you got to be more caring along the
way he gonna let you have some Trials
come your way that's going to have to
produce that in you
thank you
what happened to my life was getting
where I've gotten to today and where I'm
even headed to I had to be tough
so he toughened me along the way
I had to learn how to appreciate a lot
so he took everything you won't
necessarily succeed at everything the
first time you're trying
that's okay
some of the most successful people in
the world are the ones who've had the
most failures
JK Rawlings
[Music]
who wrote Harry Potter
her first Harry Potter book was rejected
12 times before it was finally published
Michael Jordan was cut from his high
school basketball team
he lost hundreds of games and missed
thousands of shots during his career but
he once said I have failed over and over
and over again in my life and that's why
I succeed
these people succeeded because they
understood that you can't let your
failures Define you you have to let your
failures teach you
have to let them show you what to do
differently the next time
so if you get into trouble that doesn't
mean you're a troublemaker it means you
need to try harder to act right
if you get a bad grade that doesn't mean
you're stupid it just means you need to
spend more time studying
no one's born being good at all things
you become good at things through hard
work
you're not a varsity athlete the first
time you play a new sport you don't hit
every note the first time you sing a
song you've got to practice I have
failed
far more times than I've succeeded far
more you you will never succeed more
than you fail that's not how it works
you know why because failure is a
wonderful teacher
it's the only way to learn you have to
fail
Ure is a part of the process to becoming
successful I tell people this all the
time Michael Jordan the greatest
basketball player in the world he took
946 game-winning shots
946 times since he was in high school
the ball has been in his hand to take
the game-winning shot with no time on
the clock he has only made 146 of those
he has missed over 700 times but he has
made
146. you know what they write about when
he make it
they write about when you make it so
guess what when you get through fail and
fail and fail and failing all you got to
do is make one
all you got to do is make one so when
you fail it's a part of the process keep
going you're supposed to fail
do you know that gets it right all the
time that's impossible you have to fail
matter of fact when you fail be glad
about it every time you fail you one
step closer so every time you fail say
whoo got that out the way go to the next
one fail again okay I got two out the
way
what's going to happen is if you just
keep keep swinging you're gonna get a
hit a baseball player gets paid millions
and millions of dollars
for a 300 batting average that means out
of every 10 times he goes to the plate
he only hits the ball three times
they're millionaires they only hit it
three times man please
I can't wait to fail and to have a sense
of resilience and be able to examine
what is it that I did not succeed at
why didn't I succeed and what do I need
to do better well I've found that most
people fail in life not because they aim
too high and miss most people fail in
life because they aim too low and hit
and many don't aim at all
it's pretty easy sometimes to to feel
beaten
when you're faced with all those issues
and all those problems and they all hit
you at the same time
but
let me tell you that
that doesn't mean give up
in fact it means the opposite
it means it's time for you to fight
harder to dig in
means it's time for you to go on the war
path